for me the acting seed was planted when
I was in school in in high school you
know and it was I fell in love first of
all with the with the literature you
know I was bored out of my mind I
remember like one Wednesday one wet
Wednesday like totally bored out of my
mind doing Henry the fourth part one and
in in in a moment of the teacher reading
parts of Henry the fourth part one I was
suddenly brought out of it out of my
kind of you know dream state and and
just into a kind of hyper focus because
there was something about it that I
really just resonated with me you know
that I am that I really related to and
so for the next couple of weeks I
thought that I discovered Shakespeare
you know and I was telling everybody you
know there's this guy he's really
interesting and and I in the end decided
that I would check out the sort of
format that that Shakespeare was writing
for so we had a school theater and and I
auditioned for a part and in the play
that was coming up which was measure for
measure and played Angelo in the end and
that was really the beginning of it for
me so it was really the just keying in
to shape the King into the literature
finding it relevant and passionate and
interesting and and that's what began
the journey I was at the London Academy
I was at lamda and there were auditions
and although traditionally you know
strictly speaking when you're at drama
school you don't audition for the part
professionally but because it was a
Spielberg film and because it was
considered that it would be interesting
useful and you know we were allowed to
audition a number of people were allowed
to audition and and I got the part and
that was an incredible sort of journey
but you know 19 to go from London over
to the States to Los Angeles to make the
film and that was really my transition
into into filmmaking even though I'd
never really considered myself a thought
of myself as a
an actor and it wasn't an ambition of
mine actually I was I wanted to do
theater and I wanted to be a theatre
actor and that's all I saw for you know
in terms of being an actor and and even
having made the film with Spielberg I
still wanted to be a you know wanted to
be a theatre actor so I came back to
London and carried on working in theater
and and was lucky enough to go off to to
do a couple of plays actually at the the
National Theatre not long after I got
back and so and that and then you know
but that's sort of balance you know I
guess once you've got a taste of that
sort of film language you know the it
became a question of wanting to really
have a balance and have both things and
go back and forth when I had started out
one of the main things for me was I
wanted to experience a lot of different
roles a lot of variety in what I was
doing and really explore the sort of
parameters of the craft in that way and
I think that was a really useful way of
beginning and then I mean things do
change you know over time and you become
more interested in maybe just a few more
specific things and really exploring
those you know the kind of narrow but
deep kind of way of looking at things
and and that is a useful thing as well
but I wouldn't start like that you know
I think I would start with trying if I
you know I think it was the right way to
begin to try and do as many different
things as possible to try and really
explore as much as possible because it
is a profession that allows you to
explore so many different worlds and
it's it's one of the great things about
it that you can go to all these
different spaces and so I was lucky
enough to be able to do some of that I
think that the first thing that you do
when you when you are looking at a part
that you're gonna play well for me
anyway is you work out it's sort of meta
isn't it it's like you work out how
you're going to think about the part you
know it's like you can't just apply
you know one size fits all methodology
to to playing apart you know different
parts sort of require different things
in the first part the first part of the
journey in a way is working out what
kind of part it is and so and then
working out how you're going to approach
it some parts I feel a very sort of
research-based you know and you try and
find all the sort of background
information of either the character at
the time you know you build a world for
the character and some times it's about
a kind of physicality
I've definitely you know have parts
where I've felt like if I understand
physically this character if I can do
what this character does physically then
I then I'll get into the mindset then I
understand the character it doesn't
matter so much what they do it
intellectually well with 12 years a
slave the the I think that was one of
the characters that you know was a very
research-based idea first of all there
was the book you know which is you know
first-hand account are by Solomon
Northup of his experience right there
you've got a lot of you know you've got
a lot of bases covered you know you have
an external understanding the world
around him and you have an internal
psychological understanding of the
person and the script the first draft of
the script was very very very heavily
based on memoir obviously so the
character you know was so strongly off
the page of the memoir of the book so so
that's that's one way and then also you
know the nature of the sort of slightly
more holistic sense of it you know of of
the slave trade of that period in
history of the of being you know I went
down obviously to Louisiana and started
to spend some time on plantations and to
really just get a sense of the place and
and really to feel it in a really
visceral way so in a sense that was a
very kind of holistic experience it was
very immersive it was all of the
elements which are the best kind of
experiences I think as an actor where
you are utilizing all of it you know
your utilizing all the physicality all
of the intellectual sort of Saia that
all the psychological nature of the
character in your researching you know
all of it in order to come to that place
where you can where you can be you know
totally inside of it inside of that
inside of the story with the welcome
with the director I think you know the
most important thing is that you have
clear communication channels and that
you are both working on the same project
you know and and approaching it in the
same way and that I think a lot of that
can happen before you even start and
should happen before you start and and
obviously in theater that's an easier
process because you'd be working in
rehearsals for a long time and so on and
so you'll get a sense of and a
clarification on the fact that on the
way that you're all sort of approaching
the part but but that's that's crucial
you know if you don't want to sort of be
in a process of trying to figure that
out sort of day to day you want to have
a pretty good sense that you're all
approaching the character from the same
same direction sometimes it's very
obvious you know from the script but
other times it's a little more
complicated it's it's important to find
to find ways of communicating that are
quite clear challenges are an
interesting thing because as an actor
you want you want challenges I mean you
sort of don't want challenges in this
slightly more general sense just a sort
of life sense of challenges but in terms
of working challenges and things to sort
of overcome and you know that's a really
big part of it I think it's a big part
of of artistic life really
to not be too sure to sure-footed at any
particular moment sometimes the industry
itself will give you that you know other
times you are looking for that within
within the character it's kind of
important to not feel too safe or to
secure in any given part or moment I
don't know if it necessarily lends
itself to the best or the strongest work
you know so there's you know just sort
of pushing yourself and finding the
challenges a really important
understanding what it is that most
frightens you and and sort of rushing
towards it is a great way to learn and
also a great way to to surprise yourself
and to sometimes produce really strong
work when I started you know there are
there are so many things that I think
now I wish I had I wish I had known that
I could that I could be brave you know
that I that that was important you know
it was important to push sort of
boundaries for myself and and and
eventually I did learn those things and
I did try and do that you know and and
it did help but even if I did had an
instinct to do those things I think I
was or you know caused me a lot of
stress when I was starting and actually
I think if I was to speak to my younger
self or something I would say don't be
so stressed about it
you know enjoy it enjoy being frightened
enjoy being worried about things and be
brave and just you know be courageous
and just and push because there that's
the only way to really to really
understand the industry I think and
understand yourself artistically but any
artistic form anything this is all about
its self expression and so understanding
self is
is crucial to on I feel to unleashing
you know your sort of artistic ability
so I would say that I would say you know
really do try to have an examined life
as well as doing all the other things
that you're doing but try and really key
into who you are what you feel about
things and how that informs the choices
that you make as a as an actor and as an
as an artist broadly it's a very very
important part don't sort of just kind
of go with the flow of it you know take
the time to check in with where and who
you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]